the movie opens up at night with a group
of poachers sneaking into an animal
reserve their plan is to capture some
animals and sell them for money jaizelle
one of the poachers has prepared a
special sedative to immobilize the
animals the leader of the group Toronto
then reminds everyone that their mission
is all about making money and satisfying
their investors as they make their way
air cat spots them and starts making
noise Jazelle annoyed by the disturbance
uses her special sedative to Toronto
takes a shot attempting to tranquilize
the mircat however he mistakenly uses a
gun filled with a zombie virus not the
intended sedative unbeknownst to them
the mircat opens its eyes and transforms
into a zombie as they leave Tone's going
to feed good on Pumba next the group
splits into two with Toronto leading one
group containing boys and jaizelle
taking Lane as her partner while at the
location Toronto and his team hear a
loud noise and think it's an animal they
turn to shoot it but to their horror
they are attacked by the zombie
mircat resulting in the deaths of two
members while Toronto narrowly escapes
meanwhile one of the poachers is
casually listening to music an unwise
Choice when trying to capture wild
animals suddenly the zombie mircat
approaches him and bites off three of
his
fingers grub this sends the poacher into
a state of panic making him run off in
search of his leader on the other hand
jezelle and Lane arrive at the place
where a porcupine and its baby are
staying they succeed in capturing the
baby but as they are about to leave the
mother emerges from its burrow angry and
threatened Jazelle uses a tranquilizer
gun to incapacitate the mother porcupine
but at the same time the Rangers led by
Officer Randy Hawk arrive at the scene
and apprehend the poachers Randy
instructs his officers to take Jazelle
and Lane into custody he then checks on
the injured porcupines and places them
in a cage to transport them to an animal
center Randy questions Jazelle about the
tranquilizer she used but she avoids
giving a straight answer and simply
laughs it off the next morning officer
Randy contacts Brooke a staff member at
the animal shelter to inform her about
the attempted theft at the zoo he also
mentions a strange toxin injected into a
porcupine and asks Brooke to investigate
it personally upon hearing this Brooke
tells her colleagues about the situation
and they quickly head to the zoo for
further inspection they also arm
themselves with weapons just to be safe
meanwhile Toronto and the guy with the
injured fingers are attacked by the
zombie mircat where's Pumba huh they
attempt to escape over the wall but just
then a zombie Rhino charges at them
resulting in the injured guy's death
despite the horrible sight Toronto
somehow manages to escape elsewhere
Randy and his team bring the porcupines
to Brooke and inform her that the
animals are displaying unusual behavior
Jazelle and Lane the captured poachers
are also brought to the Animal Center
and confined to a room until further
notice Randy then reaches out to a
rescue team for assistance but is told
they can only arrive in about 6 hours He
suggests to Brooke that she take care of
the porcupines while he looks after the
poachers he's trying to act brave but
he's really just afraid of porcupines
afterward Brooke administers three doses
of tranquilizer to calm down the
aggressive porcupine and worries about
the cause of their violent Behavior
while she and her assistant Logan are
attending to the animals the only
remaining male poacher tan arrives in a
state of panic he desperately strikes at
the window seeking help Randy and the
other officers bring him in and question
him about the situation in reply Tano
mentions that all the animals in the
area have gone berserk and claims that
his friends were killed by reanimated
Mir cats the Rangers skeptical of the
story suspect that he might be under the
influence of drugs was there a w hog too
you freaking dumbass nonetheless they
decide to take him to the mircat
enclosure as they believe the other
poachers may be found there in the next
scene Brooke begins examining the blood
samples from the porcupines while Randy
and his group head towards the location
where Toronto claimed to have seen the
zombie Mir cats Toronto keeps insisting
that they should return to the lab
facility for safety but the group
doesn't take him seriously and makes fun
of them to their shock when they arrive
at their destination they discover the
lifeless bodies of the poachers who had
broken into the zoo the previous night
as Randy investigates one of the bodies
they hear unusual and angry noises
nearby suddenly a zombie arvar attacks
one of the Rangers beginning of the
alphabet baby Randy tries his best to
shoot at the creature but his efforts
prove futile by the time the group
manages to kill the deadly arvar it has
already inflicted a fatal wound on the
Ranger's chest leading to his death
meanwhile back at the animal center
Brooke examines the porcupine blood
sample under a micros scope and makes an
astonishing Discovery the porcupine
cells are mutating at an alarming rate
perplexed by this finding she approaches
Jazelle and questions her about what she
used to infect the porcupine elsewhere
Randy and the group decide to return to
the research center and seek help
however when they contact Brooke to
inform her of the situation she reminds
them about the volunteers KD and Ford
she mentions that the two are about to
release a baby hippo into a nearby Pond
and requests ry's assistance with that
task upon hearing this Randy tries to
reach KD but unfortunately he is taken
away from their Jeep and doesn't hear
the audio alert at the research lab
Logan is assigned to inject a syringe
into the porcupines however when he
looks into their cages they appear to be
broken suggesting that the animals have
escaped panicked Logan carefully
searches the lab and comes across a
porcupine behaving aggressively he
attempts to approach it to administer
the syran but the zombie porcupine hurls
its sharp quills at him deep deeply
piercing his body hearing his screams
Brooke rushes to the room where she
finds her colleague struck in the head
by a porcupine Stinger tragically Logan
loses his life leaving Brooke terrified
she then makes a desperate run for
safety in another room in it chilling
turn of events the two zombie porcupines
slowly approach her from behind Brooke
seeks Refuge under a table trembling
with fear however the porcupines soon
discover her and launch an attack while
she manages to block some of the
porcupine Stingers with an object her
hand gets injured in the process to
defend herself she grabs a fork and uses
it to electrocute the porcupine causing
it to self-destruct after this she
extracts The Stingers from her arm one
by one later more screams are heard as
it turns out the baby porcupine is
attacking Lane in another room jaizelle
who initially appeared Brave hides
behind a cardboard box in a corner
crying for help fortunately Brook acts
swiftly and covers the baby pork cupine
with a metal bucket before it can harm
Jazelle meanwhile Katie and Ford are
releasing the baby hippo from its cage
when they hear a loud sound approaching
them to their horror they notice a
stampede of rhinos charging towards them
the two run for their lives but it seems
impossible to outrun the zombie rhinos
thankfully Randy and the others arrive
in their Jeep and offer them a safe
Escape as the Relentless rhinos continue
their pursuit of the humans Ford
unfortunately falls out of the car what
an idiot and gets trampled fearing for
his life the police officer hands his
gun to Toronto in the back seat to deal
with the Rhinos Toronto begins shooting
at the animals but their escape options
become limited and a cliff looms ahead
back at the animal center Brooke tends
to her wounds and contacts the police
station for assistance realizing the
gravity of the situation Jazelle offers
to help find an antidote for the zombie
virus that has infected the porcupines
after some thought Brooke makes Jazelle
promise not to engage in wrongdoing
again and then agrees to collaborate
Jazelle then kindly suggests that Brooks
should get vaccinated as she might have
gotten infected by the virus in the next
scene the two embark on researching a
cure for the zombie virus Gizelle
eventually makes a significant discovery
that the virus in the animals can be
neutralized with the assistance of human
blood Brooke is impressed by this
breakthrough and they proceed to
manufacture a sample of the antidote
this must also mean that humans can be
neutralized by animal blood which means
that Charlie Sheen is just fine
meanwhile the cops are still having a
hard time trying to escape the zombie
rhinos their Jeep crashes during the
ordeal compelling them to continue on
foot toward the Animal Center while
crossing a river they come across a
massive python but Randy successfully
manages to scare it away mine's bigger
he says and it leaves back at the
research facility Jazelle and Brooke are
preparing to test the antidote on the
zombie baby porcupine however before
they can do so the porcupine attacks
them and escapes through the window now
they have have to venture outside to
find another zombie animal for
experimentation after some searching
they come across a crocodile by the
river while injecting it with the
antidote they must also fend off the
crocodile's attacks remarkably the
crocodile regains its senses and swims
away marking their experiment as a
success elsewhere following the python
incident Randy and his team decide to
return to the Animal Center by using a
boat and navigating the Waterway as they
approach the shore each in their
individual kayaks they confront a
massive zombie hippopotamus in the water
this formidable creature targets them
tossing KD into the air and engulfing
him as he falls seeing this the other
two paddle hard to reach the shore while
being pursued by the hippo fortunately
Jazelle arrives on the bank and uses the
antidote to shoot the hippo to their
relief the antidote provides temporary
relief granting them enough time to make
their escape inside the Animal Center
Brooke is Overjoyed to see Randy alive
she is about to share the news of her
pregnancy when suddenly a loud noise
from the bathroom grabs their attention
Randy suggests they wait in the hall
while he investigates to his
astonishment a massive zombie crocodile
has managed to break into the room
through the sewer it appears to be the
same one from earlier this proves that
the antidote only offers temporary
relief from the virus not a permanent
cure or perhaps their syringe just
didn't Pierce its scales how did they do
that anyway because of this Jazelle
proposes that the antidote should be
enhanced by mixing it with human blood
containing antibodies making it more
potent she is determined to return to
the lab to work on this enhanced
antidote however in a tragic accident
Jazelle stumbles over the zombie
crocodile's tail and gets bitten by the
creature zombie or no zombie that's
going to kill you Randy tries to fend
off the crocodile with a fire
extinguisher but his efforts prove
futile sadly Jazelle passes away leaving
Toran heartbroken later in the afternoon
a rescue helicopter arrived bringing a
glimmer of hope however a grim turn of
events unfolds when one of The Rescuers
disembarks from the helicopter without
noticing a zombie lion approaching
nearby Panic ensues as everyone screams
for The Rescuer to flee but he is unable
to escape and the lion fatally bites him
in the neck ending his life instantly
Simba wants to moan back with no other
option the remaining survivors Retreat
to the Animal Center to seek Refuge
outside an increasing number of zombie
animals gather surrounding the center it
appears that the animals are on the
verge of breaching the final line of
defense right then Brooke takes out
three antidotes prepared by Jazelle and
suggests they inject each one of them to
enhance their chances of neutralizing
the zombie virus when the animals bite
them as all this is happening it
suddenly Dawns on tan that the situation
is his fault because he was poaching
animals so to redeem himself he takes
the antidotes from Brooke and inject
rects himself with them Toronto then
decides to sacrifice himself for
everyone's safety especially Drakes even
though others want him to stay inside he
uses a spray that attracts zombie
animals to him after this Toronto rides
a motorcycle out of the room with all of
the zombies chasing after him with a
badass taking advantage of this
distraction Randy and Brooke manage to
escape and fly away in a rescue
helicopter unfortunately a zombie mircat
also gets on board and they have to
fight it after a tough battle Brooke
throws the mircat into the helicopter's
propeller finally allowing them to
escape as they sail away they notice
that the animals are returning back to
normal sea this means that they have
consumed Toronto who is full of the
antidote prepared by Jazelle subscribe
for more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching